all right what's up everybody we've got
something totally different today
this is a twitch only stream we are
doing this just on twitch today
um as i recently mentioned um oh people
are taking their clothes off in the chat
it's already getting crazy i've
previously mentioned
that i've been invited to
play in what is going to be called pog
champs 2 upcoming big big chess
tournament of 16 streamers of different
varieties
um and it is going to
be at some point in the future you know
i've been invited i've been invited is
all i i'm supposed to say so far
but one of the uh people
who has been uh deputized
to teach me is levi rosman
and he is also a twitch streamer at
gotham chess and he's going to be
joining me soon and we're
going to start exploring like just how
bad
am i at chess and i don't know what he
has planned so i think we're gonna we're
going to figure it all out
um and it's going to be it's going to be
great i'm keeping an
eye now on what's happening over
on gotham chests just to have a sense of
it looks like levi
has stepped away so we're going to
figure that out very very soon and very
powerfully i might add
uh is it does it is it pronounced levy
levy rosman
i don't know i i that's actually a fair
question i don't want to mispronounce uh
it's like weinstein and weinstein you've
got to be very very careful
um looks like people over in his
stream are already complaining about my
pronunciation
levi levy levy
jeez we've got to figure out each
other's name
i think if it's all going to be if it's
all going to be working
um so in any case welcome to everybody
who's watching on my stream
and there's there's just going to be a
lot of different things going on over
the next
basically month and a half because um
because of this tournament which i have
been invited to play in
and hopefully will be will be able to so
i might just send a message here
let's see maybe i'll just hit maybe i'll
just
join and we'll see
oh okay hold on let's see i'm we're
going to get this going i've i've been
told that during chest streams technical
issues are
very very uh normal and and even welcome
so we may even have some uh technical
issues coming up and then it's just all
going to be fantastic
so let's just listen in brie let me see
what's going on over there
let me unmute see what's happening
oh we might be listening to each other's
streams right now it's really unclear
what's going on
oh here we go
correct david pakman the pundit the
pundit
now we're just streaming uh
no um
david is an invitee uh to the upcoming
chess celebrity tournament wow
i don't think he has any idea so there's
no details announced yet uh but certain
folks are kind of giving it a shot
right and very good
this is actually compelling i don't
think i actually need that
okay in any case i'm gonna i'm gonna uh
let him know that i'm ready whenever
uh i'm ready on zoom anytime
let me oh i've got i've got to be
following jesus this is all getting
crazy
oh i've got to be a follow i just
followed okay i'll just join
the zoom and then we'll see when when
this all gets going
this is this is just all much more
scuffed than i'm used to in a lot of
ways you know we have like we schedule
these things
very far in advance and it's just a
whole different scene you know
um but anyway we're going to be jumping
in on that soon
and um this is i've been invited to a
chess.com event which is why we have
chess.com up on the screen
and um this is uh i have actually
multiple coaches
that are going to be helping me so i'm
looking forward to it i mean it's just a
completely different thing it's a break
from politics it's a break from all of
the toxicity
uh and it's just going to be some chess
i'm going to do the best i can i
actually am
going to be taking it seriously a lot of
people you know might might not
let's see i think we're we're actually
getting connected now let's see
uh start video uh
are we on yes well we're we're live on
my end are we live on your end can you
guys
we are so live you can't even imagine
how live we are right now
let's see here there we go uh hey so i
i think i may have already do you say
your first name levy levy
or levi levy levy roseman love you razzo
okay so
isn't isn't that what i said i think
somebody criticized me because i already
had mispronounced your name
just off the top but i feel like i did
say that oh
uh i listen i'm i'm vain but i was not
watching the pre-show for
for for our show is that did you say
levy
i thought so i don't know now i'm not
sure well it's okay
let's put it this way um i've had folks
call me levi
get corrected to levy then resort back
to calling me levi um
actually my my girlfriend just told me
that uh
a friend messaged her and said i'm
mispronouncing my name my whole life oh
okay well that could be i mean that's
not i've
i've known a lot of i've known people
who have mis uh who wrote their name
wrote their name incorrectly and it
actually short-circuited me almost
hiring them which is a story probably
for a different day but once they signed
their name wrong i was like this is
probably not the attention to detail i
need
oh so you're not talking about the folks
that spell like um
you know lucy like l-u-c-i-e-e
no no no no no i'm saying someone
misspelled their legal name
oh that's that's very bad yeah that's
very bad okay
so um okay so i've sort of explained to
my audience what's going on and some
people are very concerned about what's
happening because they they're worried
that i'm moving away from
you know the political space but i'm
really not i mean i just think there's
nothing healthier than getting away from
toxic politics
and for me the way i got into chess very
casually is
it's just the complete opposite of
politics right i mean it's like
the rules are very clearly defined it's
it's it's so concrete which i love as a
break from the stuff i'm normally mired
in every single day
yeah i was gonna say um you moved from
the toxic world of politics to
potentially also the toxic world of
trust
well that was about so that's actually i
had i mean i always have material so i
have a whole list of notes because i
never want to be short of material even
if i'm just learning chess
so is it like in the in the lefty
political space
a lot of us know each other but also
sometimes we just don't
in the sense that people will tell me
about did i see
like karen iverson's youtube chat and
i'm like i have no clue who karen
iverson i just don't know but at the
same time
you do form groups so like you know i
know tom hartman and jenk and all these
different people
in the in the stress chess streaming
space
is it like everybody knows each other
uh the chess streaming space yes i would
say that we
we all know each other we all know of
each other we might not like to admit we
all know of each other
right um i can you know i can pretty
safely say that like most of us you know
you put all of us in a room
where no one's gonna throw any fists um
but there's always rivalries especially
if folks are you know the same playing
strength
you play each other on stream and
personalities might clash not everybody
is as
traditionally respectful let's say
as they might be in a in tennis or oh is
that right
yeah in a sport that everyone's always
just trying to be positive and say good
things i feel like um
for the most part it's like that but
we have no idea yeah um
so it you know so i obviously am not
very good at chess but one of the things
that i've experienced
is if i start a game against someone
and they're playing really quickly and
aggressively
i feel like it is a personal aggression
like i interpret that that person would
be very aggressive
in person but that's probably not
accurate right
uh no actually that's like relatively i
mean you could be
playing like a six-year-old so
six-year-olds also are very impulsive
but at the same time if you're playing
um yes if you're playing an adult that
actually
is quite frequently a sign of that's
just how they play
so in other words if some if i'm playing
again chess against someone who's
playing
super quickly and hyper aggressively it
might be the same type of person who
like calls my voicemail and leaves
anti-semitic messages or something like
that
well that was a little bit of a more of
a step up
than i was envisioning um but uh i think
it's it's uh it would be a type a
person i guess we could take that next
step okay no that's good to know
but i also will say that online chess
does have
uh does have folks resort very quickly
to making fun of
religion and culture um is that right
yeah i
well the anonymous folks i've never
that's never happened to me when i
played like a public
person at the same time i'm an
international master so primarily my
opponents are title players
with public accounts so i've only really
once ever had like a
brutally insulting
public player and i was like what are
you doing dude like
i mean i could i could i know who you
are it's so weird
uh but that sounds less appealing in the
sense that i thought i was getting away
from anti-semitism by going into chess
but it's i mean i know everybody knows
about bobby fischer obviously but i
i was not necessarily thinking that
that's the direction that chess goes but
i guess it's gonna we'll see how pog
champs goes if indeed i am uh
confirmed to be playing i've only been
invited so far right right no um
you know i uh i had an anonymous account
on which i was playing my real
you know openings that i wouldn't want
people to research if ever preparing for
me for a serious competition
and i had uh
i had a vietnamese flag uh and the
amount of
hate like i had like when i played a
vietnamese player they'd get really
excited they'd be like oh like who are
you you know are you from the top ten
and i'd be like i'm no i would just you
know i would write in vietnamese and i
wouldn't be able to respond
um but folks would just immediately
resort to just insulting that and i was
like
what like come on you got to do better
now that's interesting so i mean there's
a lot of ims
who are playing their real openings
online
and presumably they're playing them in
tournaments as well right so i didn't
even think of that as a strategy where
you might
play totally differently online or under
a pseudonym in order for people to have
a tougher time
preparing yeah exactly so at
the highest levels of kind of slow chess
in
in
what traditionally has been known as the
most elite form of chess
now with this whole you know online boom
i'm not even i'm
sure that's still the case but it's
harder to kind of
wrap my head around you know this this
this online uh
progression and price funds and
everything like that but yeah
you yeah a lot of it is preparing they
look at the games that you've played in
tournaments and then they also
um look at the games you play online in
my case i have like over 10 000 games
so drilling down into something specific
is going to be really difficult but
definitely when i play
you know stuff that i would play in
slower games to win important games i
have to hide that
got it which is you don't have that
problem no no no
yeah so i mean that so so i guess this
will start to kind of get into
my preparation as we may be calling it
um
so when um you know if if if i'm going
to be
i want to take this relatively seriously
and
the i guess you know first i just need
context right like
i only up until a year and a half ago i
really only knew how the pieces moved
and you know what constitutes checkmate
and just the basic rules castling i mean
i didn't know any opening strategy or
anything
so like how how old were you when you
started learning and the process of
you know memorizing things etc
sure so most if you come across a titled
streamer
uh i would say i i want to go as far as
to say every single one of us started
playing in childhood
so if it's an international master or
grand master uh i'm an international
master gm is the next one up and
even in in um the gm title there's
levels you know to the game uh
all of us started playing when we were
five four six seven
eight we were playing tournaments uh as
kids and
that's kind of stuck so i'm 24 now and i
have
i played my first tournament a month
after i turned seven right so
yeah and you know over the course of my
life i've probably played
close i always say half a million chess
games online and over the board
uh and i've played tournament games
specifically about 2000.
so so in in by the so in my position
it's not even really realistic to think
that there's going to be any significant
amount of memorization right like do i
need to understand
more conceptually than memorizing other
than maybe
in initial moves or like what's
reasonable for me to even be doing
right that's that's that's a a huge
question that gets asked um and and i
think you're you're actually the perfect
example of somebody that's trying to
learn you said you just learned the
basics as an adult right you didn't play
at all in childhood
i i played only in the sense that i
would sit in front and
i knew how the pieces moved okay and
eventually somebody would get a
checkmate you know what i mean like
it was that but there was no like actual
you know i have a few openings in my
repertoire which i'm sure we'll talk
about
you know that's been in the last couple
you know year or two
right so that's that's kind of like
always the example it's like you know
you do the basics you know you're only
recently as an adult kind of
picking things up where do you start uh
i
i recently did like a like a kind of a
question series
of of my viewers like what are your most
basic questions if you could ask an im
three different questions what would
they be
right and there's a big overlap of like
what is the chess starter kit
i mean if you just need some skills to
kind of get the game going so
for sure it's some sort of opening
repertoire uh
how you start the game with white and
black against different
openings uh basic ways to finish a game
so let's say you're winning
like you said checkmate patterns had a
win with king and queen versus king
right king and rook versus king which
i'm sure you have had to train yourself
um and so on um and then puzzle solving
you add the tactics and then
well all of us struggle through the
middle game like how do you make a plan
how do you make weaknesses take
advantage of your weaknesses so that's
always the hardest thing
uh so should i i mean should i give you
like the
the 90 second rundown of what my playing
approach
and struggles have been so far and then
maybe we maybe you just take over and
i'll i'll just go wherever you guide me
yeah that would be that would be the
best first step so take me through
um your chest from like right when you
started kind of your studies
uh where you are now maybe what
resources you've done
uh what training you've done and with
who and then
uh what do you think your biggest
strengths and weaknesses are what do you
like and hate the most
about the game wow okay i mean so
i'll just kind of go into random order
so in terms of playing
i mean the most serious study i've done
has basically been limited to
um as white i had a phase where i was
playing
uh king's gambit okay i had a phase
where then i went to ponziani
okay and then more recently i've been
messing around with kings indian
as both white and black actually
a struggle has been with uh playing as
black
uh having a strategy that was not
dependent
on memorizing exact responses to
different openings by white which is why
i think i've liked king's indian because
i think that
there's a couple in the first three
moves there's only a couple scenarios
where
black would deviate i think and i'm sure
we'll go into that so that's actually
been okay but i'm really open to you
know i
i don't know what my approach should be
in thinking about the tournament but
that's basically been like
the theoretical study um and then it's
you know doing
i've gone through all of the a lot of
the free materials
on online of checkmate patterns and so
on and so forth
um i did a couple casual lessons with
eric rosen a little over a year ago
and um we we you know may do some stream
stuff at some point
uh and then otherwise it's just been
playing i mean it's it's a weird thing
because
maybe this is a common thing but i feel
like
i know so much more about the game now
than i did a year ago
right but yet i'm not necessarily
winning that many more games or seeing
my rating go up
yeah that's uh that's fairly common
actually
uh it chess is absolutely
it sometimes you don't even feel the
reward of study
until months down the line uh you need a
break from the game uh you'll come back
two weeks later and you'll play this
beautiful game
or you'll play a game where you lose all
your pieces within the first five
percent moves you're just like what
happened
right um i really like what you said so
with the black pieces you play
so the two types of openings um setup
based openings which you kind of play
all the time and then the more
theoretical ones
uh let's we can jump into an analysis
board are you in live chess
i am in live chess right now okay
perfect so i have an analysis board set
up i'm gonna add you
you should get a invitation at the
bottom right of your screen
got it okay perfect i'm in
awesome so when you um see the board
you start out with white on the bottom
right yes
okay so i can't flip it for both of us
but if i ever prompt you to you know
make sure the board is flipped at the
top
right like right where that rook is at
the top right corner
there's a little set of icons
yep and the bottom one is flipboard got
it okay so just
um if we ever need to look at the
position from black's perspective or
white's perspective
um now primarily i saw that you play
two plus one as a format right like what
do you usually play
so on chess.com i'm playing a lot of two
plus one
because we have a lot of hurry up and
wait in the production of my show
and sometimes i'll just squeeze in a
couple games
over on leaches i'll play
often longer formats but i'm not playing
very
you know longer longer chess and one
thing i was going to ask you was for
training purposes should i be doing
slower games
absolutely so so five five um okay
five minute five second bonus very
popular ten plus zero is good but what
you'll also run into in ten plus zero
is you'll have a person that as you said
will just be
line i mean play really fast and all of
a sudden you have two versus eight
and you have no bonus time so you're in
a bullet game
again um so 1510
i think is like the best but
as you said yeah like as long as you can
and with bonus time
um and what i always say is you should
set a quota so you should play like two
games a day
maybe three and that's it and then try
to analyze internalize
yep um interesting very okay this is
useful stuff
yeah because two plus one is great but
um in the words of a philosopher hikaru
nakamura it's a clown fiesta
well i think you know there sometimes
when i'm trying things out
i have this idea where if i want to get
a bunch of looks at a particular
opening or a particular situation like
in the king's indian where
you know with am i am i advancing my
effort deep on first
depending on what's going on or whatever
it feels intuitive to say let me get as
many looks at it as possible um
but obviously then a lot of the other
stuff is not as high quality
right no that's that's that's absolutely
correct
the the only uh the only way to really
see what you got uh is is to take you
know your full game history
and i'm happy to kind of add tools for
you
like starting today so if we if you
start it with the white pieces
yep um at the bottom you can make you
know
like let's say you start the game with
your usual e4 so you would play
i think you can actually make moves so
okay
let me see okay terrific and again usual
so for i've been really doing king's
indian recently but from you're saying
from the
from the ponziani days so to speak
yeah yeah so so if you you tell me if
you want to stick to king's indian i'm
totally happy to do that
um i think actually with the white
pieces e4 is
is a fantastic move and there's a lot of
you know there's there's a lot of
weapons and you don't need to
um let's put it this way you don't need
to learn a ton of responses
at the at a lower level okay um
so you start out with kingspawn tell me
what you know what can black play here
and because i don't want to bog you down
with repetitive information yeah i mean
i think i guess
um typically these three moves would be
ones that
i think i'm coming up against most
frequently okay
yeah and that that's absolutely right so
uh e45 you're gonna face
a lot i mean probably more than three
out of every five games
yep uh sicilian so c5 you're gonna face
because
it's one of the most popular defenses
and you know i actually i tell folks
below 2000 not to even play sicilian
because the way sicilian normally
happens at on a theoretical level
is you you know you have to memorize a
ton of stuff
and i just say don't don't even you know
don't even do that i like i like the
king's indian so i really like that
um and then yeah you said scandinavian
so this immediate thing and i know you
usually take
i do yeah usually the way i yeah and
then
you know typically play the night out
and then sometimes
i will see this right sometimes i will
see like this check
in which case i'll usually bring the
bishop out
right exactly yeah bishop knight get
developed and and so on
i think for you know for a good starting
point like a in terms of opening
repertoire
which we'll we'll we'll start out with
uh let's start out with e5
uh and rather than like you know
aggressive kings gambit or knight f3
um my my community's gonna gonna know
this because i i talk about this opening
a lot but
play play night out this way first um
well in my preparation for our work
together
i did see one of your videos where i saw
that you suggested this
this is the vienna is it yes and so the
vienna has a couple of different
versions the one i'm gonna show you
is i don't really focus on it actually
uh so much uh in in the video that i
think you're talking about also i'm
honored
that's uh oh yeah so listen i have
questions about what's happening with
the chess youtube algorithm which we'll
get to
but you started just popping up three
weeks ago for some re i don't know how
or why
and but i have some theories but we'll
deal with that maybe later sure
uh well that's that's that's amazing
i want to make sure youtube gets a nice
donation so they keep keep doing it
um so i i like this move for a few
reasons
the biggest reason is that you're gonna
play this move anyway i know that
ponziani happens you play pawn here
um and normally what you're going to do
is delay the move knight f3 or just
not play it at all and what you'll do
with the knight
is either push this pawn in the future
or you're gonna put the bishop this way
and the knight this way um the last
uh participant in the tournament but i
showed this to boxbox who's
uh streams a lot of league of legends uh
but there's um there's a lot of venom in
this system so let's say i just play a
you know developing move
something like knight c6 uh what you can
do here
is go for a system where
you play for the center so something
like bishop c4
and you can you can play the moves to
just familiarize yourself okay yeah
that's good
so bishop c4 is kind of like the
traditional way of doing things and
again we're
we're waiting with this night so let's
say i play like knight f6
yep and now you prepare this move
with pushing your d-pawn so up one
square
exactly uh and your your next idea is
going to be
you know you want to go here and then
you want to play
knight behind the pawn so in a perfect
in a perfect world
you know let's say again you play this
move
uh if i take it i hope we're clear you
are going to recapture that
yeah right okay that was going to be my
first question yeah you don't need to
delay it it's not a gambit at all it's
actually
now what do you think is the benefit for
white to make this trade
a few moves down the line what's going
to be the benefit uh i mean i'm guessing
maybe something related to
having some influence in in this
direction earlier and prevent maybe
making it more uncomfortable for black
in some future moves
so first of all yes your bishop is going
to get developed and you're going to
have like you know the two central
bishops which is
excellent uh you don't always get that
and
the second benefit is going to be
anytime a pawn is traded and this is
just
generally moving forward as well files
open up
a lot of diagonals open up so since you
traded your f pawn
the f file is more open
yes and so when you put a rook here
hopefully with short castling
you're going to have an active rook
because normally there's a pawn here
sure and so the rook is stuck behind the
pawn so long term
you're trying to create something on
that side of the board
or you will castle this way
yep otherwise so so when you say or i
will do that depending on whether
this uh exchange happens on f4 i will
castle one way or the other
that's a so that's a great question when
i when i say or it's
it's actually more of a matter of like
um it's it's honestly completely up to
you
okay you can play the position the
ensuing position
with short castles or long castles and i
know that's like well that's
why wouldn't i stick to one way because
in chess consistency is super important
but uh you might find that you like
putting your king this way
and just you know going crazy on the
side of the board okay
um but if you castle the same side as
your opponent
it's harder it's harder to attack on you
know the same flank because
okay so so in the event that this pawn
is taken i immediately take back with
the bishop
if it's not let's say i go here for
example
what do you think you should do here uh
probably move the night out
okay perfect see you didn't forget about
that like that's how i know you know
your
your continuity is is absolutely right
like you don't need to get distracted
with this
um because you know that if this happens
we have this right though so i mean i
guess this is a good time to
so one principle that i've i don't i
don't think that
it's necessarily been i mean that i've
picked up on i guess
is i tend if i have uh if there's a
possibility to
create a trade or wait for a trade
earlier in the game i'll usually opt to
put one of my pieces on a better square
knowing that i can always
that the piece is defended and i can
trade later or now rather than choosing
to trade i'll wait and develop a piece
okay sure so what you're saying is
you're not gonna you're not rushing into
trades
for the sake of simplifying the position
yes not certainly not early anyway
right yeah that's that's good because
actually folks played the complete
opposite way
like a lot of people like to trade like
five six pieces
immediately and you probably have played
against folks like that who
yeah it and you know now the thing is
when that is happening when it's very
clear that someone is trying to do
something so belligerently
chess is not the kind of game where you
go i'm not going to let him do that
um because that like what you're what
you described in that sentence is an
emotion
and that has no like that sentence does
not make any sense on the board because
on the board
the best move and the best plan is
always the same you know it's
it's kind of the same conceptually you
can't just go i don't want that to
happen
right so sometimes very early on
trading a bishop for a night not good
just generally speaking seven eight
times out of ten why
you know you know this imbalance right
between bishops and knights so
um i think in in the end game the
bishops
are better yes and in the middle game
yeah and so conceptually speaking if i
challenge you
do you think that a person with two
bishops versus bishop and knight
wants to open the position or close it
or
does it matter well with two bishops
i mean i guess i've been in situations
where with two bishops i can start to
really
harass the king over to one side of the
board maybe for as part of some broader
plan
so so it seems if i had the two bishops
i would want
open or close i guess i don't know i
guess maybe more open because the
bishops would have long diagonals on
which to operate
yes exactly so that's sort of how you go
a little bit deeper into that concept
like for example if your opponent played
the move bishop g4
in this position the whole opening phase
is not just about developing uh
your pieces and your pieces only i mean
it's also
still a dialogue between your pieces and
theirs so
in this position what i would do is i
would say okay what do you do if i just
attack your bishop
right and if they hang around
this bishop is very suspiciously placed
yeah i mean in this i've had
this situation on the side of the board
often and usually i'll
just keep pushing forward perfect and
then if they go here this is actually
very common in the vienna
ah right usually in the openings i'm
playing
i'm not getting this third push they're
usually back to a space that is real
like inaccessible for me
or at least this pawn would be under it
would be in a space where it could be
taken
so i guess that that that's different in
this opening yes exactly uh there the
playing this like system with this
expansion on the king side
you will trap that bishop it will happen
uh and
well because folks like they go here but
they don't really think it through they
they kind of stop at okay i'm just
pinning this knight sorry
uh you know they stop it i'm pinning the
knight uh
and you go okay and if they take it
i hope we're on the same page about what
you're taking back with
well so let me think i mean i i guess if
i take with the pawn
uh i've got the open g file for the rook
but if i castle then it's actually the
king that's exposed right so maybe
that's not so good
yes you're absolutely right it's better
to take with the queen in this position
uh because if you take with the pawn um
i i honestly can't add anything to what
you said you're
yes and double puns i guess unless
there's a good reason for it i want to
avoid it
uh okay so this yes this this is very
commonly kind of
stated i'm not so sure how how badly
you need to kind of implement that um
concept i would say okay let's put it
this way doubled pawns which are
isolated
and could be targets yes
double pawns which are supporting the
center which are well protected
not quite the same but everything else
yes everything else is 100 right
all right um so queen would be yes
okay now i play this let's test your
tactical vision what's the best square
for the queen to go
um well black's g-pawn as of right now
is undefended
so so g3 i would be immediately
attacking that pawn
and i guess potentially forcing black to
have to react to that um
where else i mean f2
would put the queen with some i mean if
that
uh knight eventually moves the queen
would potentially have room to do
something
um and then maybe i guess i would try to
avoid
e3 even though the pawn is there i try
to maybe avoid
lining up the queen and the and the king
so yeah i mean i guess if this were me
playing i would probably
go for g3 okay so
this is where i'm going to uh have you
heard in any of my videos me say checks
captures and attacks
checks captures and attacks yes okay so
when and just chest thought process in
general so obviously when that night
pops in
the first thing you do when a move is
made is you go
what does my opponent want it's not
about you
it's actually first and foremost it's
about them yep
so when you see the queen is under
attack right i say god i gotta move my
queen well if i go here i'm attacking
this pun
yes but you didn't finish you didn't
finish that first thought
there's oh i'm gonna get forked on c2 if
i do that exactly so
so that when you finish that thought
process
it becomes a lot easier to go well what
do i have to do i guess it would be
ff2 or or even d1 right yes
and so they're both fine but f2 is a
little bit better
why well i'm not totally undeveloping
the queen
okay perfect uh also we can call this
not an attack i like to call this just
vision so
the queen has vision on the night and if
anything goes wrong
you'll take it yeah and you know you can
even like this move next move
is adding an attack yep so
yes bishop b3 would would attack the
knight now this is this is a great move
um
now let's say i i will go
here let's let's play through this i'll
maybe maybe i'll you know i'll leave you
off with with castling so you
finish your development and now i'll
play a move like a6
so let's play a little bit okay and then
at some point will we back up and review
the standard moves that i should be okay
yeah good yes absolutely
okay um okay i mean
at this point i might be thinking
something like this
um
would maybe be a move i would think of
or i might push the b
pawn maybe i mean this is usually
actually where
if i have an opening plan this is where
it becomes pretty ambiguous for me where
i'm not really sure like how i should
structure
the the plan going forward so b3 and
bishop e3 are
are both fantastic moves uh because well
be i guess b3 i'm starting to do some
calculations because
because i get what you're saying b3
bishop b2 so uh
b3 tactically would not work i just want
i just want to show this i
i spoke too soon i was just focusing on
your development but b3
what is wrong with b3 can you
uh what is wrong with b3 i know it looks
like crazy that that could be
so checks captures attacks
for yourself is a easy way to solve
puzzles
now add that to your opponent if you
play b3
he can't check you well he can but both
moves lose a knight
right right both loses a knight he can
take this and what does that lose
uh that loses that the other night yeah
exactly i guess he can also
he can take everything else which is
guarded so then attacks how does he
attack you
in this position safely um
one of your pieces i'm actually not sure
perfect that's good because if you knew
everything then chess would be very
simple so
it's better not to know i mean i'm
thinking so so
with this night you're saying no no no
uh
with anything so oh i say this book yeah
um yeah i'm still not sure how that move
puts me in a in a position to be
attacked
so i guess you can go piece by piece now
pawns i wouldn't
like you you don't need to go oh he can
attack one of my pawns or something
because there's not there's no pawn in
the center of the board that can be
attacked at the moment
yeah this is all well guarded your
pieces
you need to see if there's any way he
can put one of your pieces in danger and
so
this is the move uh okay yeah and
now your only safe square with the
bishop is
here yep and i just hope you understand
when i say safe i mean that
sorry i mean that that's a fair trade
yeah right so
but then there's this
and your bishop is dead right
so it's crazy that that can happen that
fast and now
white is just down a piece i mean we you
know there there's not much you can do
here
um so it's crazy that move like b3
but conceptually speaking do you see why
your bishop got trapped
conceptually speaking uh let's put it
like
uh oh i guess blue is not the right
color let's do
well i mean that pawn structure limits
the escape squares for the bishop
yes that's yeah exactly so
uh it's it's the fact that you know
three light-squared pawns behind a
light-squared bishop
right they're shoving him off a cliff
and saying jump into the lake and so
there's this bishop has to hang out here
whereas at least here
you know there's an escape escape square
for the bishop to always kind of drop
back to
and price trade is fine for the future
if you ever want
getaway square for a bishop on one of
these diagonals like a3 is always very
useful
and then you can just slide back
and then from there you'll have the same
kind of pressure makes sense um bishop
b3 the move that you suggested
excellent move uh because it creates an
attack on my knight right you are
literally threatening to take this piece
yup so let me go
here
okay um
i guess i i'd maybe be thinking about
pushing my f pawn
to f5 okay
taking some space on this side of the
board yeah and you know oh maybe
opening up some space for the bishop and
the pawn is protected by this pawn and
you know there's kind of like some
action happening
so i start i mean you know in these
situations i don't necessarily have a
clear idea of what my eventual attack
would be
but it just sort of seems like maybe i
have something going here that i could
develop
so f5 the what is the difference between
these two moves taking the pawn
and pushing it let's say you take it
optically speaking well
i'm i'm opening space if i take
whereas i'm kind of keeping things
closed in if i just push
yeah it's it's more like the f file is
opening up
in your favor but at the same time when
this happens you know
you you do kind of allow the queen to
have vision rather than
it's not a threat it's just it's now
taking part in the game
on the d-file yes um okay yes very good
i mean taking
or pushing are both kind of they're both
kind of equally how should i say
uh annoying for black because uh
they both take space they both open up
the position i think between the two of
them this trade is a little bit better
oh because you at least now have you
know pressure here
so in terms of
you have a a middle game position and
it's like what do i do next so obviously
you're always looking at
attacking something capturing something
tactics should always be kind of
whirring in the back of your head uh
let's say you do play this move queen to
g3
yep you're eyeing this you have vision
on this pawn
you're like okay i'm gonna go here have
you ever seen this kind of checkmate
pattern
where you have this and then yeah so
very typically in this situation
i would try to play here you know given
that the pawn is pinned
and then usually what i what ends up
happening well i guess in this position
i'd have to look at it but
sometimes if it's very dire for my
opponent this pawn comes forward and
i'll end up taking the rook
and you know there's some you know trade
that happens on that square that's to my
advantage
yes exactly so
when you start looking at at all this
stuff you have to
not forget what your queen was doing
on that home square and so that's kind
of like the
the lesson in and of itself is that
you've got to go okay i want to go here
and then i want to go here and i want to
go here
yeah but what happens when this happens
again right right
that doesn't matter because i have this
move
you're not fully wrong
if you think this way right um but again
the thought process there
is if he takes my rook
then it's made that thought process is
correct
that is a correct thought process but
there's something amiss
we're assuming that the rook will be
captured and that's not going to happen
so that's how you have to think in chess
if you have
four ideas three work one doesn't
you can't play the idea the original
idea because if the opponent finds the
one move
that stops your whole plan it doesn't
matter that there were three good plans
like if that makes sense
okay so but in this particular situation
are you saying
i shouldn't be worried about the rook on
a1 because if there is not a defense
here then its mate
yes so that's that's exactly right my
next question was going to be is there a
defense
for black um
well it's this right so g6 is kind of
like the the last resort because then
you're going to lose your rook
that that is usually what has to happen
if you have no other way of defending
uh maybe here perfect so that moved both
defense and attacks
yeah and actually this has happened to
me before yeah right and that move sucks
for you because it's like oh okay and
then you know if you go here
now can we take this rig yeah right
because if you take the knight let's not
forget that this bishop is now under
attack
right so because the position will
change a little bit that used to not be
the case
yep um and yeah that's that's that
that's
i mean that's kind of a little bit about
plan making so one idea that in a
position like this
i've had before would be thinking about
if i play here
um
and then this puts pressure this way and
the queen can't take because this is
defended
so that would be something i would think
about i don't know if it would actually
work
so knight d5 as an idea
is exactly where i was going it's like
if you don't have a direct attacking
plan you don't have a weakness that you
can target
what trades in the position are
beneficial to you
yes and why so knight d5 is is the best
move it's the best move in the position
oh interesting
yeah so wow i'm shocked that that would
be
my go-to that's well i mean and also in
thinking about
you know this entire idea this also
would get the night away
from being able to end up defending here
there you go yep so you see you have the
ability i think it's also from
experience because you've played a lot
of games you have the ability to see how
a piece ties together you know two parts
of the position which is yes
yeah and so knight d5 is is excellent
now
if i take you already said that you
would be taking with the bishop
um but i'll i'll let you have it because
i feel as though that was
that was very well done uh let's say
with with the black pieces here
um i play the move
queen d7 so i defend this
yep that's hanging right yes
should you take it my instinct without
calculating it is no
okay why um well
so if i take it and then the rook takes
back
okay um and then i take here
and the king moves away
then what i don't know that it
am i coming out ahead i mean i guess i
i'm coming out ahead in a literal sense
that means up material right
i'm up material but i don't know i mean
i i don't know that i'm actually
ending the game and maybe i'm getting my
pieces uh out of position for some
future defense i don't know
so the way the way a chess like you know
like for example myself i'm looking at
this position i see bishop f7 that's a
free pawn
is as far as i'm concerned because i'm
even skipping over the fact that the
rook will take
because if the rook takes then the final
position with the king here and it's
your move
you're still better off right so the way
you evaluate a position i mean the
the easiest way to think about this is
uh am i up material at the end of my
idea in this case you are you have a
rook and a pawn for a bishop which is
a huge advantage that's plus four yep
which is that's almost
that's almost like the game is over on
the spot basically right well if i were
better i've me i've lost plus four more
times than i can imagine
you know i i i know but see that's one
of those like uh extra
extra add-ons right yeah it's like i'm
not sure i can win this who the hell
cares you have to play it it's the
best move so you you have to play the
move bishop takes f7 and so
you say okay am i plus four yes if not
that's when the position gets a little
bit more confusing if it's like am i
i'm plus one but is my
queen overextended am i going to get my
queen trapped
so that kind of leads me to this like if
king h8 so that's
that was going to be my next question so
now essentially i
i either need to move the queen uh
in order to defend the bishop with
something worth less than the queen
right or i need to
i don't know i mean attack the queen but
i can't really do that so i'm not i'm
not sure
right so you're already starting to look
okay i'm pinned i can't move my bishop
uh are you in danger not really no
yeah and even if it was black's move
uh i don't think black can do anything
because you're defending this way too
much
right so you have to uh you know you
have two defenders on this position so
yeah
so you're not in danger um and you're up
upon you can't move for
just a moment here so you know
what would be next you don't need to go
bishop e6 because
you can calculate well if he takes my
queen i take his queen but he's not
gonna do that he's gonna take the bishop
right and so you know we don't have
anything there so yep
um what what are you thinking here
let's start thinking in terms of two or
three different ideas
candidate moves okay so i would look at
c3
but then i still have the the move of
the knight coming to c2
and then attacking the rook on a1 and
then i've got to defend that oh right no
actually i could take it with my queen
right and the bishop is still defended
by the rook
okay perfect so so does that mean you
play c3 by the way
well i would think about other moves
first exactly so just because you you
found
you know your thought was like yeah he
got knight c2 but oh i just take okay
great c3 is the best move in the
position
right no because then you could have
seen could have missed something
completely different right so
yeah you know so okay c3 first of all if
not knight c2 what is he going to play
if not knight c2
um
if not knight c2 i'm not sure uh
it's gotta go backwards yeah
i guess maybe knight c6 or knight b5
yeah knight b5 knight c6 and actually
this one you can make your life a lot
simpler than you can just take
and then you would have the difference
being
that uh you know at least you're winning
a knight for
whatever it is that you were trying to
do over here right
so c3 is a great move uh you have other
moves but
there they're much more mysterious
for example you know you can like
probably play a move like this to just
bring a rook
um you can play a move like queen d2 as
well
which gets out of this pin yes so queen
d2 is probably the most natural and it
keeps this garden
so that might be the move that gives you
the least headache
right just queen d2 and and and gets
that the way let's say you play c3 and i
go here okay
so with these two moves what has changed
in the position
um the center is much more open
center's much more open and in
particular
what is attacking what now now
what is attacking what now the
well potentially there's this
okay but it's remember the opponent just
moved so before you even think for
yourself
look at what they're attacking now
um this pond exactly that
that's what changed your pawn move
weakened the next pawn
and so that well that's actually the
threat
if you if you play bishop c5 by the way
uh calculate that for a second so bishop
c5 your opponent will play what
um well i mean i guess would
would they take this and then first yep
yeah then i take with the queen and
what's changed
what's changed now after those bishops
left the board
um well the pawn on d3
remains undefended correct and there's
something else
hidden always do like a little piece
scan of uh is your bishop on f7
um oh now the queen has access to that
square
the black queen yeah yes and uh bishop
c5 would
actually tragically result in the loss
of the bishop because
that transformation added the queen yeah
and so
from a distance that's hard to see
as you're moving up the ranks the fact
that that movement
you know added that however it's very
easy for your opponent they don't have a
big job they just take the bishop and
take the other bishop
yeah and that's where we make mistakes
we see things from the distance and
right it you know they're kind of
incorrectly uh
you know incorrectly say so that just
means that this is a bad move but
we didn't play it that was just an idea
right so we should keep this guarded
how do we do that um well i mean i could
look at
pushing that pawn okay no that's a
terrible idea because the my opponent
has one two three four pieces
defending that square yeah okay i don't
want to do that exactly
but it was an idea just because the idea
doesn't work doesn't mean like you know
the player is like
a [ __ ] like it just doesn't work like
okay it might be a good move in another
position
sure so i mean i guess now i would think
about bringing
one of my rooks probably the rook on a
in line with the queen
yeah i think rook d1 is a is a is a
perfectly reasonable move
um rook rook d1 defends this pawn uh
the uh but there there is there is
something very evil here
which i will just show for instructive
value
yep um that bishop that you have pinned
to your queen
how can your opponent add an attacker to
it right now
[Music]
um
right now uh let's see
oh well no i'm not even sure actually
add an attacker to that
oh moving the knight back to d8 yeah and
that really sucks like
i mean that just sucks yeah uh
and there's nothing you can do because
uh you you know you need to invert these
pieces like the right should be before
the queen
yeah um yeah i mean 98 is just and a
backwards night move that wins material
is the hardest tactic you'll hear this a
lot uh so that's actually the reason
rook d1 is bad but like
how can you tell that this is bad
because of this
that it just has to do with the focus on
the focal point of the position
which is this at the moment
um and so that is why yeah you should
play a move like you know queen to e2
for example
because that sidesteps this yes
um and the way kind of i'm trying to
intertwine more general things and kind
of the general thought process to the
game
because the truth of the matter is we
have this position in front of us now
but you will never have this position
ever
again right probably that's how chess
works um
so you can't sit here and go okay i'm
gonna memorize like
right of course yeah it's more like you
know for the future is this a good move
yes if you can find the follow-up
to maintaining your you know your pin
here and getting out of the way
is this a good move yes i was most
impressed with the fact that you found
knight d5 i mean that was
like that was amazing uh because that
it shows you understand the difference
between this trade
and a trade like this which
this accomplishes nothing for your
position right it just gets rid of you
know it just gets rid of your bishop
yeah um exactly so that's that that
that's that's fantastic and i mean we
can we can sort of pause
here uh and the way you kind of learn an
opening and then practice the opening
is you get the setup down a few times
and you go and play
and you go scan how it's going you go am
i playing it right
uh am i making the transition from the
opening to the middle game correctly
uh or hey i lost in seven moves like you
taught me some [ __ ]
well so on that note can we go back to
the beginning just so like we can talk
through that yeah
um okay let's see so my my goal
my the goal for my second move is is is
this
and i do that only if i am responding
to e5 or in a number of different
scenarios
so exactly so against the e4 e5
primarily
but you can play this move against
uh sicilian as well okay so knight c3
and
we'll we'll add that later but for now
let's let's focus on this one
okay so at this point uh knight to c3
exactly knight 63. um now last time we
looked at this knight
but we can also look at the bishop out
okay um do i play my bishop out in this
case
absolutely yeah okay your your game plan
is going to be
this kind of this kind of thing yep so
d3 f4 knight f3 and then i guess the
question is
situations that would interrupt it
exactly
okay first and foremost uh this crap
okay so um
i guess i mean do is this what i'm
looking to do here yeah so g3 is fine
because this can't be taken
right uh that that that can't be taken
uh probably the best move
is to guard with the queen oh okay
and i but it's it's it's very like i'll
say that g3 is uh
is completely fine as long as you
understand that
you know when you put something on this
square it will be a little
more vulnerable yes so
you know your queen guards but you
should be a little bit careful you might
consider even
you know long castling okay so just get
you know getting getting the king the i
i
don't want to play a committal pawn move
so something like this
got it followed by this
you know the night out the bishop out
and notice how last time i told you it's
about moving this f pawn forward
yeah just because you can't get it
doesn't mean the game is over
you just still follow you know basic
developing principles
so that would be this queen move would
be sort of like an exception move where
i would change my plan
yeah if your opponent just goes for some
okay something ridiculous
let me just play a natural developing
movie yeah so then at this point i would
play here
perfect yes uh i will play
d6 okay
so let's say i play
knight c6 now i bring my knight out
you bring your night out exactly
i can play
castles at this point would i castle
so here's the thing oh right i can't
castle right now okay
exactly oh so this is common to this
position right yes it's actually it's
it's it's actually not the end of the
world um but this is kind of black's
most
challenging approach okay like does not
let you get exactly what you want
is is this black playing perfectly in
defense
of the vienna yes okay okay and so that
that's that's kind of why
i've i've added this element is that now
you don't just get to go here and here
and then you know destroy
yep um the best thing to do for you is
to block out this bishop
and open up the bishop coming to g5 okay
so at this point i would i would play f5
yeah yes exactly f5 is the best move
okay there's there's no way to strike
back in the center because you have that
you know completely shut down i don't
want you to panic
if you see this so this kind of idea
yeah uh because actually if you just
move your queen first
now what is this is this is preferable
to this yeah because then you would
block your bishop
oh right there okay fair yeah exactly so
so queen like this
uh if i jump in here with a knight all
that's doing is attacking a rook
so that i
i moved the rook and i still eventually
could castle over here
exactly yeah okay and we've already
started making progress on this side of
the board
yeah so yeah i'm i'm showing you this
because like if you were a complete
beginner i wouldn't do this
because i would say like okay you know i
need him to castle his king early
otherwise
bad things are going to happen but king
in the center is fine
as long as you have control of the
position yep and you do
because there's only three pieces i will
go one more step to show you
what if i check you
um i mean i guess uh
so i guess these are my three options
right or or i guess i could take this as
well
and and then i'm trading my queen for a
bishop and a night which seems like
that's not really a good move yeah
no we want to move the king for sure um
so i guess my
instinct would be so if i move here
i'm potentially connecting the rooks
except i'm blocking
the bishop on this side eventually i
guess i could go over here um
if i move the king over to d1
um then i'm i'm allowing the bishop to
develop
sometime soon which seems preferable
maybe yes
uh and if you go well the thing is it as
far as the bishop developing the king
moving to either of those two squares is
equivalent okay
uh but i think long term
if your king stands right here it it
it's not going
to get to a side it's still on the side
and so if you go to f1 when you kick
this night out
it can just hang out right there okay
and it and and it's pretty safe now both
of them are actually okay
but more than anything else what i'm
what i'm kind of trying to show here is
that
uh we're breaking one of maybe the rules
that you have learned early on
which is you got a castle you gotta get
the gang safe
uh and we're adding a little bit
of opening flare so
allowing our opponent to overextend into
our position but understanding that it's
not actually any
danger to us um it's just two random
pieces
and our king is completely safe so
one question here just because i i have
this uh actually if so if we're
here sure i very often will
sometimes i'll just say let me just
attack the queen
oh it's not actually my turn right now
okay so let me go back so attack the
queen
knowing that this is coming and then i
just move back is there any real sense
to doing that
uh well that move at the moment is
impossible so bishop g5 is a fantastic
move
oh okay so you're a genius
[Laughter]
um okay this is not normally the
scenario i face but but this scenario
where my bishop is defended by my knight
in this position
and the queen can be easily defended by
moving is this a wasted move for me
so the way you can think about that is
most likely yes it is like a finesse
that doesn't have to happen
however sometimes it's very good
and so the way you got to think about
that is what does them making that like
let's say this move is possible
what does them doing f6
do to the position uh at an elementary
level you say does that move like
blunder a bunch of pieces
right if the answer is no like let's say
that move was legal
yeah you would say okay well then i can
like maybe move my bishop here and then
i cover that
yeah yeah that would be very smart that
would be interesting
it would be a tempo winning move you
would force your opponent to
to react to that move and then you would
retreat
uh sometimes in chess
moves like this win the game a move that
you know
you force a move out of your opponent
and then retreat
but doing it for the sake of doing it
usually
bad unless you see exactly like what is
next
okay um i would say yeah got it i mean
sometimes this type of thing
can be used to um
potentially move two puns out of place
which may be to my advantage but i guess
you're saying unless there's a real
specific way that i know it's to my
advantage it's not really worth it
yeah because again if you apply the same
logic it's like okay well if they do
that then great but what if they don't
right and then if they do it fantastic
but if they don't then it might it might
actually end up being
yeah a waste of uh a waste of a move
okay
um now i'm it's it's kind of more my job
i feel like in this you know in in these
streams to
uh give you multiple
ideas and things to think about yes
rather than
okay uh david here's an opening and you
must play this for the remainder of your
life
uh and the tournament because first of
all by the way like let's put it this
way
if you know if the show goes on and you
play this opening people are gonna start
seeing that yes and they will start
training and it's good to have
options right so another way to play
this if you you know if you're maybe
okay
find that you're a little uncomfortable
opening up your king
is way back here to put the bishop in
fiance style king's indian style
okay and prepare the f4 move
a little bit more slowly so i'll show
you what that looks like so something
like this
so g3 bishop c5
like this and then preparing this move
by moving
this and this right and then that so
that's more reminiscent
of just a king's indian open
right exactly uh and it's it's a little
bit different than king's indian because
in king's indian you wait a very long
time to actually play the e4 move
right uh so in a perfect world what this
looks like
is something like this where you
actually castle you
you move very far along in this whole
process
you actually even move your king this
way because you're out of the pin
and then something like this you got
this protected and
then and only then do you start you know
doing this kind of a thing
okay and and this expansion and uh
it's it's kind of up to you like maybe
you play one of them but you don't like
having an open king
so you would play this one the good
thing about this setup
is you can play like this against the
sicilian also
okay so let's just play through that i
mean you you know i just i just showed
it to you so let's
i'll play with the black pieces go for
that setup with the bishop here how
would you
oh okay right so in the sicilian
it's not great to put the bishop on c4
uh do you have any idea why
um no but i'm wondering if it has to do
maybe with these pawns eventually coming
forward
yes it's the fact that the opponent
never moved the e pawn and so they can
just go
like this right so a lot of people don't
realize this a lot of people actually
get asked this a lot th
this thing bishop c4 has a name and
you know different like different chess
sites will pop the name up in the top
right
and they'll go do you know the bibity
boopity thing
and i'm like i don't know what that is
so it turns out that there's a name to
this move
um and you know they'll say well i play
this and i say well it's
it's not great because then they can
just you know go here right um
and then the chat will say well they
never do that
and that's the age-old question it's
like should you play something if it's
bad but no one plays
the right way i don't know you know i
i don't know where you draw the line but
but so that would be a modification
where if i see that that
black is playing a sicilian instead of i
would opt for the fianchetto
exactly and you could do this against
the kingspawn but if maybe you say okay
against d45 i'm always putting my bishop
here because it's more aggressive okay
got it yeah uh and
you would set up yeah like we can play
through this let's say i play like
d6 okay
g2 uh knight out
so now i would play here you actually
can you you can play that right away and
then you wouldn't even have to do this
move oh okay oh so in this setup you
that there this is a possibility first
yeah yes
uh when the bishop is out in
the kingspawn position because obviously
now
we can't we can't do that in the
sicilian yeah uh
you might have difficulty playing this
move and then not having the right to
castle so as we've seen already in
different
uh versions of this opening you might
just have to go long
right you're not going to be able to
castle short but yes 92 is possible you
wanna play a four like
totally let's let's go with this so okay
i'll play uh e6
uh okay oh so i guess now i would play
the knight
you can play the knight and also you
know from moving the f pawn early that
you can put the knight behind the pawn
oh okay so so that that's interesting
yeah i guess i i didn't
necessarily think it was better in this
position to do that but
but you think it would be uh it's it's
your call
oh okay okay you can do either so if you
play if you play the the pawns out like
this
yeah then uh then the knight f3 is
totally okay so sometimes in these
positions i end up just struggling to do
anything with this bishop and it's
almost like a dead piece sometimes and
very often like
if if something like this were to happen
i end up having a situation where
other than undeveloping my only move is
basically just
to leave it attacked by this bishop yes
and i'm sure you've actually also seen
that from the king's indian on the other
side
exactly yeah and that's it's it's a
long-term piece that's gonna stand on
that square like you're gonna have to
try to open the position
yeah uh and that's kind of why
you know i've been i've been pushing it
toward this but it's hard to
maximize the piece when when it stands
on g2 so there's there's pros and cons
this is more solid for your king
whereas this is a little bit more you
know more active for the bishop but your
king has
has potential weaknesses actually like i
i told you before the show like i have
you know chats open somebody's saying
uh let you play a game out what's gonna
happen is you're gonna play this too
early and your king is gonna get too
weak well that's how you learn an
opening
you've gotta play it and you gotta go
okay this game i did something stupid
and i need to
um
you're gonna get into some sort of
trouble yeah so
uh but that's you know that's that's how
you have to play through things
um let's also just give you a couple of
things
with the pawn coming here whether
immediately or
you know the french on the karakan uh
how much experience do you have playing
against
all of these openings with like the pawn
coming to d5 um i mean
so so the d5 pawn is what i have the
most experience with i i certainly i'm
i've dealt with this i just don't have
any strategy so it doesn't stick in my
mind to something
you know that i know what i even play i
sort of am like in a figure it out as i
go along situation
okay got it so essentially these two
ones who push you know the french and
the karakan
uh they want to push the pawn here and
then have a pawn supporting
obviously whereas this guy is saying
i watched the john bartholomew video and
so now i know what i'm doing
uh so you bring the queen out and then
actually oftentimes as you said the
queen goes all the way to the side or
all the way back
yep and then easy development after that
so
what i recommend against this is
actually rather than chase the queen
right away just get your king castled
oh okay so knight f3 yep and then bishop
e2
and just just do this okay because
people freak out
unless they're queen you know if if
their queen doesn't get attacked
they'll actually just do something weird
and malfunction
um so for example knight f6 go ahead so
so bishop v2
say i you know same i just developed and
then my goal here is before you put this
knight here
the knight would be a lot more powerful
in the center of the board
with two pawns there right so that's
what i like to do against the
scandinavian opposition now would you
would you chase the queen away right
away ah you
so i actually i like to veil this threat
by playing uh
something like d4 first oh okay because
that still keeps this on the board
right uh and in the future if they
play inaccurately like let's say i don't
know they
something like this like they don't now
you have this and that
right and there you go so you have
the ability to veil the c4 push
and then push the d-pawn forward and now
you're you know
attacking straight down the middle of
the board makes sense
okay so the big change for me is that
typically
uh i attacked the queen yes so so
instead here
um the idea is i'm playing here
here oop here and then castling yes
exactly
you're not actually playing into uh into
the attack
of the queen you're just gonna get
developed and then two pawns in the
center
got it exactly okay against the others
like this
uh well it's generally good practice to
put two pawns in the center of the board
if it's possible without losing one of
them you put two pawns in the center
yeah i mean it's you know you don't need
to go for this whole setup thing we
we only do that against those two
okay so king's pawn and sicilian so i
would put two pawns in the center
so you should play d4 and then on d5 uh
what's called like a placeholder
so i'll just show this to you as a as a
four
now and then get some more games under
your belt and we'll kind of start adding
on because i don't want to
throw you know heaps and heaps of
information
uh just take the pawn oh okay
interesting
typically in this position i've just
been pushing this pawn forward but again
i don't really have a strategy it's just
like i'm kind of
you know figuring it out yes exactly so
the
that is a perfectly challenging weapon
uh for now though
you know a french defense player you
have to understand when you play this
and you're saying i'm figuring it out
they've they've done some study ah right
they know exactly what to do they're
gonna go here and you're like uh
okay i guess i should defend my center
and they're like all right perfect
that's chapter three of my course
you know boom and you're like etc etc
so the easiest thing just for now let's
trade
yep and let's just get castled so here
bishop
castle okay now in this position
is there ever any point to this check
aha no okay good yes no
uh well that was too confusing answers
back to back but
um the answer is no uh
the only benefit to it to a straight
down check like this
is if you develop your pieces
and castle and they don't so something
like i don't know
this the rook check is very strong
okay okay the queen check is not because
the queens can just get traded
right this is very different um and
and what you're doing now is you're
actually starting to punish them for
being
lazy in the opening so let's say they
play bishop e6 you can already go after
this bishop
how um like this
bishop f5 is one way what's another way
another way would be here
yes perfect um which of those do you
think is better
um maybe with the knight
okay now tell me why well because i'm
forcing if i do
take here i'm attacking the queen which
means
essentially this this move is almost
guaranteed to happen i i guess
i can plan around it better than if i
leave
other options i don't know
that's uh i think that's that that's
the best explanation and also we can
also
think about it from the perspective of
the end game is that your bishop
ah right okay will just be a you know a
long range piece bishop five is also
a very reasonable move okay and the
threat is to
uh just win the pawn so yeah bishop
takes and
and so on so yes uh queen check not
quite but okay this this rook check yes
absolutely
is it it is always vicious uh
now we can do
this so
whenever you're you're doing a lesson
stream
and you play a game like on chess.com
and we play through it together
to talk you through a thought process uh
you it's not
i mean you can't do that so your
opponents will get a rating refund
and so that just allows us to play
through a full game and you get to kind
of talk your thought process out to me
and i get to tell you okay this is good
this is not so great yeah um
so if you want to uh
can you play a can you seek a 15 10 game
do you even have any 15 10 games like i
don't think so
i don't know that i have any yes so
you're provisional you're 1178 rapid
so seek a 1510 game and i'll follow you
okay and then
oh and you know what if we're going to
do this i should actually shut something
off that otherwise will go off while
we're playing this
oh okay yeah let me give me 15 seconds
just to step away and do something here
let me see how to do this here we go
hello i've been left alone with both
streams or maybe i got muted did i get
muted
so much power right now
you guys enjoying the show
is this going on youtube what's youtube
mine yes
it's tough because you have to do um
openings to start like openings are
always a good starting point uh
different grandmasters say different
things different title players to
different things but
openings are a really good way to you
know confidently start the game
and understand what you're doing early
on because chess should not be a mystery
you shouldn't be reinventing the wheel
chess is not a game that requires that
let's let's put it this way
so you should be confident starting out
the game and then
adding on all the extra layers that's
how i approach it anyway
my laundry would have gone off and it
would have been so embarrassing
it was in the speaking of end game my
laundry was in the end game there
okay so explain so so basically if i
play this
and then we're talking through it it's
sort of like even though it's rated it's
not really rated
yeah i i mean i i'll literally just dm
somebody from from staff and be like
okay uh this person played you know
me and you so got it uh
so someone has challenged me to 1510 do
i just hit should i just seek randomly
or uh you should speak randomly yeah
because people are gonna snipe you
and okay like there's a i don't think
we're gonna have this problem
uh but when the big gaming channels
would play they would get like
literally somebody who's 800 points
underrated or using an engine or
cheating you know got it all right let's
do it here we go
okay well okay you have white so i like
how his name is only toxic one three
four
all right start out with e4 perfect
yep uh okay so sicilian okay so i still
play my knight out to c3
yes that's exactly what we talked about
but i'm not going to do this
so i don't see your arrows but if you
say the moves out loud i will okay i'm
not going to bring my bishop out to c4
nope let's see what he does i mean you
will if he plays e5
right he plays bunny five yeah but he'll
probably play yeah so most people play
knight c6 no just g3
so
it's a very non-confrontational opening
i don't know i mean sure why not um okay
so now
i fianchetto my bishop yes so bishop g2
is the plan
uh monitoring you know each of his moves
to see
now he'll probably play e6 or g6 or d6
okay he played one of those two
so now i would play f4
you can yeah f4 is perfectly reasonable
right now
okay
so you already have some ideas uh for
example if it was your move right now
what would you play
well the old me would maybe look at
pushing to e5 up until that happened
what do you mean the old u that's the
best move
oh well not anymore though not the
president not anymore no not anymore
okay so now i would bring the knight out
i mean i guess i would bring it out to
f3 yeah
exactly so you're blocking your bishop
but the other knight covers the center
yes yep so this is uh this is so far so
good
very passive position for black very
passive so
let me move the clocks down why are my
clocks so high up okay
that is the first move you actually kind
of have to think about like
okay so my instinct just on my chest
personality
is not to take the pawn on e5 because
it's defended by my g-pawn and to try to
play a move that that helps me like
maybe castling
okay so that's one of those more more
general like kind of
inner you know uh kind of frameworks you
have
which you did say earlier you don't want
you don't want to trade too quickly
um remember what we talked about
with uh with the vienna system
yes you would rather take that pawn with
something
like your dark square bishop on c1
um you're oh you're saying if
if that pawn were to be taken it would
be good to have my d-pawn out of the way
so that the bishop could be used to
capture back yes
so something like d3 here is one of one
of the moves you you don't want to take
back on f4 with the pawn
because in the future you won't have the
f file right okay
so d3 would be it would be a reasonable
move here yes d3 would be would for sure
and just in case anyone is is concerned
uh
i already sent staff a message
but uh listen this this frankly speaking
is the best way to learn the game
yes especially if you're getting you
know some form like it has to be through
the
uh through the actual live live thing
okay
that is a move i suppose
so um this is actually
we had something similar earlier where
there would be really no idea
for me of taking with my knight on d4
because then as soon as the pawn
captures back the other night is under
attack
yeah exactly like this trade is um
it on d4 in particular is not
it's not bad for you but it's also not
very obviously
good for you either uh so what are your
what are your ideas here
well i mean i could put a second
attacker on d4
by playing my my dark squared bishop to
e3 but there's two pawns defending that
square so i don't know that that's
really a great idea
i could castle or i could play
f5 maybe okay so taking some space
yeah five is an interesting move it's a
very committal move
yes uh don't forget you also have
something else with your f-pawn in these
positions
i could take right and so if you take
and he takes back on e5 you have
i have a free pawn right with my knight
yeah and so
the right move for him and that's
actually something like a byproduct of
what he did he played too many
repetitive moves
notice how he moved his pawn twice and
then his knight twice
you can't do that like he can't play
there's got to be something so
take the pawn i've got your pun um
you can sort of punish mistakes very
early on now everything else you said
bishop e3 and castles and f5
all good moves okay all good moves so
his best move here is to take your
knight
ah right because then that's no longer
going to be a pawn i can uh
take yeah yes but how many moves with
the knight that he make all right
that'll be the third one
and he and now it's gone yeah so he's
only helping you
really right like a guy who's like you
know developing the knight
jumping it forward and taking your
knight has no idea what they're doing i
mean they're
just yeah so let's see well i mean in
his defense i have no clue what i'm
doing too let's not uh
you're too humble i think you know it's
good to be okay so now i have to take
with my bishop obviously
why oh well actually well uh i don't i
can take with the queen
oh actually that seems better i think i
prefer to take with the queen and then
this knight is also still under attack
yeah yes it's queen is queen is best
yeah
queen is best you're gonna notice this a
lot now you say well my light squared
bishop's not great you're not wrong
you're not wrong but that's that's just
part of this setup okay so he takes
again what are your what are your
options here
um well let's see i mean that now might
be a good time to
to bring the knight out and maybe now is
a good uh opportunity
to pin the uh the f6
knight to the queen and maybe force
some pawn move to try to attack my
bishop or something like that
so bishop g5 in and of itself is a very
good move
uh but if he plays h6
you can't hang around like right you
either have to take the knight
you can't go to h4 because you actually
get trapped i get trapped yeah yeah
so what are the pros and cons of playing
bishop g5 and then taking on f6
of bishop well i mean i guess the
um the pro would be
i'm simplifying and maybe i have the
initiative and i'm the one forcing some
of these
some of the way the game is going to go
i guess the downside is i'd prefer to
have the bishop
myself available for later in the game
yeah so that's that's actually a correct
like con it's like you know you're
giving away the bishop but
for um
for a pro simplifying is not a
like that's not a it's only a pro to
simplify the position
uh if you're winning already so if
you're up material you're simplifying
okay that's good
but there is no real way to say i'm
simplifying the position when it's equal
therefore it's better for me right what
you're doing there when you take on f6
you're hurting his pawn structure right
because what's gonna happen is he's
gonna double his f pawns
and when he doubles his f pawns the
light squares in his position like d5
f5 are gonna be clear targets and if
he's doubling his f pawns
you have an open f file right so you can
play bishop g5
now the other thing i would think about
would be bishop to e3
bishop b3 is is also an excellent move
so what would be a way i could decide
which is preferable i mean i guess it
just i guess
the the idea of taking on f6 if i'm
committed that that would be my plan
then it makes sense to do that because
it's a specific idea maybe
well the way we talked about it yes but
he also can play bishop e7
when you move your bishop out you can
also and then and then you know your
bishops kind of clash
so i think i probably prefer bishop to
e3 so do it
yeah yeah so so essentially you're not
what you're doing here the way you can
talk like think about this conceptually
you're not making a committal decision
just yet
like if you're thinking okay i'm gonna
go bishop g5 then i'm gonna castle then
i'm gonna play knight d5 and i'm gonna
just destroy him
well yes but let's pretend our opponent
is not a [ __ ]
like that's the most important thing
that we have to do
so uh okay by the way he played bishop
e7 now my question is which way do you
want to castle
um so i i in this position i would
probably go
long only because in looking at it some
of the pieces
that would immediately be protecting the
king i'm going to want to use for an
attack
okay and so it feels safer to go long
okay now i'm going to urge you
to start thinking about what uh that
that checks captures attacks
if you castle queenside look for
an attacking move for your opponent do
you see one
if i castle queenside he has a move that
puts you in danger if i castle queenside
yes only if you castle queenside
um is it queen to a5 well does that move
attack any peace
i guess not well i mean it attacks the
knight but it's obvious you know it's
defended by yeah so we just we'll skip
that so it's not even attacking it and
it's also not attacking the pawn in the
corner
because the same knight is guarding
right so it's not queen a5
is it bishop e6 well no because the same
thing
the knight is guarding yeah
black has one move and only one move
which actually creates a material threat
to you uh
like quite literally put something in
danger would it be
knight to d5 no no not knight c5
queen now queen b6 wouldn't be it either
yeah i guess i'm not sure
bishop g4 bishop to g4
ah okay and so because then i
might i can move the queen but i lose
the rook yes that is extremely difficult
to see
yeah i actually almost wanted to let you
play along castle just to see if it
would happen but i don't want you to be
like what the hell man
yeah yeah yeah okay so that's not a good
idea so you can prepare
long castling by making bishop g4
impossible
so how would you prevent bishop g4 um
prevent bishop g4 well i mean i guess i
would move the queen now
you don't have to you just prevent uh
you cover the square one more time
maybe with the h pawn h3 okay
all right let's go for that and see what
happens and i see folks in my chest
saying like i wouldn't have seen that of
course because long castles and bishop
g4 don't look
now let me ask you did you see bishop g4
by itself just a move that could attack
your queen
no not at all okay so that's how we're
going to win this tournament
we have to the the best chess games
the the players are envisioning moves
for each other the entire time
right and if there's one skill that
you'll pick up
it's spotting stuff for your opponent so
castles now you can do long castles as
you were planning
um and uh well this by the way this is
why 15 minutes is so great because yeah
right
the game would be over with a shorter
format yeah
we would have played like four games
already uh
but yes guys we we
we keep talking about uh the tournament
um there's like nothing out yet but
uh david is gracious enough to join
for potential as a as a pogchamps
inviting so bishop v6 is a very good
move now is a really really
tough spot yeah what do you play
so um i i
usually am unsure what makes sense to
play here i think my
instinct would be to either push my g
pawn
or play b3 so b3
you you you're playing because you're
blocking his bishop right
but b3 does nothing right and i'm
defending the a
the a pawn with my knight anyway
yes exactly so he's not actually
threatening the pawn on a2
right g4 is the best move g4 oh okay all
right
the best move i mean the thing is you
cancelled on opposite sides and
when you do that you're it's it's a it's
a pact
and the pact is to attack the guy okay
so
yeah g4 for sure is
is for sure the best move who do you
think has a better position here
um uh i mean i guess i
i think i i maybe do the the knight
on f6 can't really go too many places
um one of their bishops is blocked in
by the c pawn um
so i think i mean i it seems like i
maybe have more opportunity for
initiative here
wow b5 is a very aggressive move okay
first things first
is that a free pawn um well let's see
if i take it is it a free pawn
um it looks no because then i lose the a
pawn
first of all a2 does hang uh and second
of all
it's just a very dangerous pawn to take
i mean it's it
it's a move that accomplishes nothing
except opening up the position for your
opponent
right then they play queen a5 then they
play rook b8
yep uh so yeah now you might say well i
have to
if that pawn comes forward it's going to
attack my knight that's correct but
weren't you the one attacking a move ago
right
so i i mean like i i might now play g5
that's you have to play g5 yes okay
because you're you're striking first
my instincts aren't terrible right uh
your instincts are fantastic
terrible somehow i end up losing all the
games but i feel like
there's a certain point at which my
principles are helping but then it just
falls apart
we'll get to that i'm sure yeah no but
that's i mean that's chess you know you
can play 40 good moves one one bad one
and you lose the game
right right that's that's absolutely
that's why it's why people hate chess
and love it i suppose so
but i i completely understand and i have
had games like that and
the worst part is that you know
chess.com two plus one game is one thing
sometimes you play a chess game and you
spend seven hours and you don't win
right and well that that
sucks yeah that's that's another story
that's a big matzo ball hanging out
there
i i had monstable soup for lunch today
so oh no way
you know what place in manhattan has
great matzo ball soup it's probably
closed because of coronavirus
it's called uh jack's wife freedom
yeah yep it's a i've been there it's a
brunch spot in soho
it's one gigantic matzo ball is the only
thing
oh i've never had their matzo ball soup
but i have i have had brunch there
yeah uh where that's one thing i didn't
stalk well enough you're not from new
york you're from
where are you from i'm from argentina uh
you're you're in argentina now
no no no i i live in i live in boston
now but i'm from
i lived in new york for two years though
ah yeah
okay well there you go now let me ask
you a question in the move 98
what is black doing what is black
attacking anything um
yes because now the uh bishop the dark
squared bishop could take my pawn
and if i take back with my bishop then i
lose the bishop to the queen
very good so see that's something that
we uncovered
last analysis knight moves pieces
attacking has nothing to do with the
knight
okay so you can defend that pawn in a
few ways you actually have to because
there's no point losing that pawn
yeah i mean there's h4 or moving my
queen
to g3 or even to h5
if i wanted oh actually interesting
queen h5 uh
yeah i only looked at queen g3 and h4
which move do you like the most
probably h4 okay so play it yeah okay
i'm i'm i'm going to get to the point
where i'm going to walk you through the
thought process and i'll let you play a
move and
if you blunder you blunder because i
can't i can't literally play every move
got it yep but so far your instinct is
absolutely right
and uh i'm in between moves i am
dropping the ban hammer on people for
anti-semitism in the chat so that's just
an added uh
an added activity that's happening oh
terrific yeah i i
i do so okay let's i'll talk after your
move is played
so he's attacking your knight what
should you do with your knight
um well i i probably put it on e2
okay if you put it on e2 what's your
opponent gonna do
um what is my opponent going to do
well you uh maybe bring the queen no you
told me before you told me before what's
he gonna do
he's attacking something your knight has
been a focal point of defense oh then
it's going to take the pawn yeah
yeah so what's the only way to move your
knight and prevent that from happening
um probably moving the knight itself to
d5
you got that exactly which but now
potentially i lose a oh no i don't lose
a pawn oh no because of my queen there
okay good
yeah you're you're you're well protected
you actually have three guards on that
night the pawn
queen and the bishop uh it's interesting
it's interesting you said so
see i guess that's something you have to
face a lot uh i'm
i'm not i'm i'm also not particularly
religious but i think getting flamed
for judaism is not i i don't face it as
as intense i get other things i think in
ch in the chess twitch world we get
other insults right um but i have gotten
that one as well
yes for sure okay queen a5
what is this so i guess the threat would
be
centering on on a2 eventually
okay um and so the
what is your best move in this position
would it be king b1 potentially
that looks like the only move so
yeah king b1
really in the nitty gritty now of the
middle game yes
very much so um so checks captures
attacks is something that's going to
have to
it's going to have to stick so queen a5
you respected his threat but you didn't
look at yours
you had something five
his queen used to guard somebody
uh oh there's now a free bishop which i
can no longer
take because i've lost so now i have to
take back yes you have to take but i
wanted you to play everyone in my chest
like you idiot you didn't let him take
the bishop i'm like
i am aware so yes the bishop was free so
96
um and so every move you're going to
have this background mental scanner of
can i take something for free or
something
like bishop takes pawn for you right now
is obviously not free
no well then we know it's going to be a
bloody two-sided attack
of the of the chessboard so what's a
candidate move to continue
some sort of attack um
well i guess i could look at queen e4
queen e4
i could look at queen f2 in order to
put the pawn in danger because the queen
would no longer be able to defend it
right queen f2 is a very good move queen
e4 was a one move blunder
was oh no i would be giving away the
queen now i've learned that some chess
players at a certain point in the game
you want to just give your queen away
is that a move that you favor or not
really oh
wait oh it depends is it always the
golden chess answer
it's uh all right yes okay in this
position i don't you let me know when i
want to give the queen away and then
i'll do it
yeah no not right now please we have we
have a good thing going for us
um so queen f2 the thing is with queen
f2 you completely shifted your focus to
the other side of the board
right and he's gonna get a little
aggressive now too so
um do you think you have to take that
pawn because if you don't what is he
gonna do
you think he's gonna take your pawn or
push his pawn i i think probably push
right so you should probably just take
it's just not
yeah so you see you have a defensive
sense like the guy wants to push and
open up your king he's gonna take this
with the knight
yep when he takes with the knight uh
is he attacking anything um
not directly i mean i can take
the can't take the bishop it would be a
trade bishop for which i would rather
not do since
i'd rather keep my bishop okay so you're
saying you want to play a move like a
bishop all the way back to c1
um not that's not the type of move i
would normally play my
my instinct would be to play b3 and then
potentially end up trading
on e3 even though i don't really want to
so my my mini lesson in and of itself
here is going to be
never push pawns where you're being
attacked okay
because it's just going to weaken your
position further like if you play b3 he
won't even take your bishop he'll go all
the way to the left and he'll check your
king
so i think i will move the bishop back
then okay so bishop c1
is is probably fine so just go ahead and
play it okay
um and i get yeah because we're we have
10 second bonus per move
yep uh but the move bishop back to c1
logically speaking you're like i don't
want to trade my bishop for for his
night
but at the same time me playing devil's
advocate his knight is attacking your
king as well
so if he traded the knight for the
bishop he would lose an attacking piece
yeah and the queen by itself is not
going to be able to uh
do that much unless the bishop and oh or
the or the rook gets
okay but the root that there's no threat
i mean it's still behind the pawn so
we were still attacking i'm going to
urge you to keep thinking about we have
to attack as well it's opposite side
castling so
how we gonna do that um well
i could play d6
but it would just uh i don't know that
really benefits me very much
it doesn't let's keep focusing on that
pawn storm on the king exactly like he's
doing
because we did it a little bit uh maybe
maybe h5
you gotta go h5 and g6 yeah you gotta
crash through so
this is called a pawn storm and it's i
think that's like
i'm not sure that's the official term
but it's a very easy way to remember
this
uh okay very aggressive
you have to take it with the c pawn
sure i'm gonna be completely honest
there's no difference
there's no difference okay c doesn't
open the a file so it might make you
feel inherently a bit more
yes that was my thought yeah but the c
is uh
cna actually i think just optically by
the way now you're attacking his knight
so yep he he's poking the wood of the
fireplace
and he just got ashes like you know
spewed toward him
if the knight moves which i assume it
will i wouldn't be
i would be looking at maybe attacking
the queen with bishop on c2
although i think it would just i don't
know that it would do that much long
term
for me right you got to focus on where
are you the strongest
where is like the the bread and butter
of your position it seems
on fgh so you got to focus yes
your next moves will be g6 something on
that side of the board don't just get
distracted with oh i have this attack on
his queen
and it's a safe move so i'm going to
play it because that's not
he'll just move his queen just like you
said yep and uh
yeah now he's thinking finally the guy
my favorite
they play really fast they screw up then
they think
so i know we're talking about g6 but i
would also
maybe be thinking about bishop to e4
okay that's a very very uh aesthetic
move
bishop before because it it hits the
corner pawn
right the only reason i haven't been
talking about it is because i feel like
he'll move his knight in front of your
pawn
and then you won't be able to play okay
before
however which case i would probably go
g6
now let me ask you a question if you
play h6
instead of g6 what's he gonna do
probably just play
g6 yeah and then how are you gonna get
through i don't know
right which is why the move that hits
both
pawns is usually better
okay because that way you will force a
trade right
but there's still some stuff to you know
to to look at there
if you look at the move that he just
played b3 by the way
he did play that move yep um so
g6 right now
what will he take with well i would
assume he would take with the f
pawn to do a discovered attack on my
queen ah wow you
okay all right so you just skipped
everything so instead of getting hit
with a discovered attack
why don't you just sidestep that first
by moving the queen
yeah what do you think the best queen
move is um
it's amazing how you just saw like maybe
maybe c2
so c2i to line up to h7 yeah
what's he gonna play if you put the
queen out in the open like that probably
rook to c1
yeah rook c8 but yes c8 sorry yeah
you see like that's how chess works you
i don't want to play queen c2 because
he's going to play rook c8
so what will you play instead maybe
queen d2
so it's off for a queen trade oh no
that's not what i was oh
uh no not actually that's not what i was
thinking um what about maybe
um maybe queen to h4 so then it's lined
up with my rook
i like that but then you can't go g6
okay because you're pinning yourself
right so
e2 e2 g3 yeah but see like that's
exactly how we're getting just go to e2
for now
okay um and then we'll have to play a
few more moves fast because this guy
that's what i mean like even in rapid
you know you got guys that just play
so fast and it's i don't get it but
so now i'm looking for g6 if possible
that's probably your next move not to
mention isn't queen takes e5
also a threat aren't you interesting to
win a second pawn yeah
queen d2 was a great move simplifying
when you're up material okay he plays it
himself
uh that's a horrible move um what do you
think you should do
well i like taking the pawn and
attacking the undefended bishop
that's fantastic okay um
wow you know i thought you were gonna go
well he played g6 now that plays right
into my plan but you didn't even you
left it there for a moment
and you said if i take his bishop's not
guarded that's like that's perfect
so you're not getting tunnel vision with
oh i gotta i gotta take on g6 no matter
what
right not to mention that now when he
pushed his jeep on forward
he's got dark squared weaknesses near
the king does that make sense
yes essentially three light-squared
pawns
the way he has means that the light
squares near his king
are well protected but the dark squares
have no one guarding them
right oh okay that guards the bishop i
was like what is he doing okay
should you take on g6 or should you push
your h-pawn my instinct is to push the
h-pawn because then it could be made on
g7
okay so play it
it's very it's almost a completely
forced win
um i think hg was better simply because
if you play h6 okay well he immediately
makes a mistake but
he had knight f5 so now the question is
should you take this f pawn what should
you do with your queen
uh so if i check on e6
then it's either moving the knight
to block or moving the rook to block or
moving the king
over to h8 there's kind of a bunch of
options so i'm thinking probably take
with the pawn and then take
the and then go to check then maybe
sure so take like both those moves you
can't quite
figure out everything that's gonna
happen yeah uh so you just play the
simple move especially in time trouble
like you don't need to create something
beautiful
yep um i have a prediction so rook f6 is
the best move
uh i have a prediction if he plays
bishop f6 he's going to be like i'm
attacking his queen
okay he does play rook upstairs we the
queen's gonna need a little bit of
reinforcement so i would play rook to d1
rook two uh you already know the e1 sure
yeah so you're not threatening to take
anything just yet
because the somehow everything in his
position is well protected
well i'd be thinking about bishop to g5
next
well i have a question why didn't you
just play that on this move yeah
actually that would have been a better
move
uh well yes it looks like it wins by
fours black has a really really
uh uh rook f5 is uh so i think
now check with the queen okay
i'm wincing but only because i don't
want to give away all the solutions
oh wait a second no okay
yes so your h-pawn push a while ago
that was the right move it set it up
yeah and so he exactly
yeah yeah very nice so queen e6 and the
game goes on
um so i can't if i make moves uh on the
board on my end you won't see them
so if i'm just going to kind of verbally
tell you like back up to a certain move
okay so instead of rookie one
on move 28 right if you played bishop g5
right away
yep that move looks like it completely
wins because it's just
it destroys everything because if the
rook moves
to any square besides f7 it's made right
and if it does go to f7 then what's like
the
the simplest thing here for white to do
today if it goes to f7
um if it goes to f7
do i take the bishop with my bishop and
then
the next move uh well i'm guessing that
then he takes with the one of these
rooks and then your next move is
i could take the night good so it takes
takes takes easy
you win a night and everything in your
position is completely safe
exactly so bishop g5
looks like it wins the game on the spot
and the reason i said like yes but no
uh at at sub 2000 bishop g5 wins on the
spot
i think right right around 2000 black
might find the defensive move here that
keeps the game going do you think you
can find
it using what you know about tactics so
i'll add in here you're attacking his
rook
but would maybe he try to fork my
bishop and queen with his
uh rook because then the rook is
protected by the knight
uh well he did that in the game but then
what did you play oh wait did he hold on
because he played rook five but he can't
cause that opens up oh no i meant
i meant rook to f5 rather than rook to
f7 no i know i know but in the game he
played rook f5 and then you mated him
with queen
oh did he oh that's not what the uh oh
rook f5
oh okay okay yeah yeah the the uh the
moves got confused here
okay so we're going back to move 28
and your question was if he played rook
to f7
so we looked at rook to f7 and it
doesn't quite work because you take the
bishop and you take the knight
yes but in this position he has a
like a tactical trick and
it's essentially like the the concept of
danger levels
so you're attacking his rook with your
bishop
right yes he can ignore the attack
on the rook if he can attack something
in your position that's worth more than
a rook
um i guess knight to f7
exactly and that move like just
a little bit prolongs the game right
because i can't do a check on b8 because
then i lose the queen
i can't take the bishop because then i
lose the queen
i guess i would
yeah what would i do here you'd probably
move the queen and guard the bishop so
you don't lose it for free
okay so like queen to g3 or something
queen g3 queen e3
yeah and you you might even have i mean
we can even argue that you can sacrifice
your queen
right now like if you played bishop
takes rook yep and he takes your queen
and then i take back but like again no
need
yep this is a no-need situation it's
still winning
and in fact it's just kind of good in
this position to to practice
evaluation of a position yeah why is
this position still winning for white
in in a general sense yeah like uh
so so using like uh material for example
if you sacrifice your queen you're up
one point
of it so it's not anything substantial
right
that goes first material second thing is
king safety
one of the players in this position has
a terribly weak king oh right yeah i
mean i have i have the king on the back
rank but
both of my rooks are on the back rank
right now so it's there's no
super easy way i guess to attack my king
exactly
yep that's uh that's it and i mean
black's king on g8 can be attacked
uh how let's like say not right now but
in a move or two how would you get to
the black king
uh you mean uh no longer targeting g7
yeah one if if the queen has been
sacrificed oh okay so let's play it so i
would take
sacrifice here um i mean i guess i would
start moving my rooks to open
files right so rook f1 rooker phone's a
good idea
if i said you have to check the black
king in two moves how would you do it
um i have to check the i guess i would
play
d6 and then bishop
to d5 how do you always find like the
most advanced solution first
because then i guess yeah well i was
thinking bishop h3 bishop e6
bishop h3
bishop h6 wait no
say that again so bit instead of pushing
the pawn and then moving the bishop to
that diagonal
yeah where you hit the king you can move
your light squared bishop out to h3
yep and then to e6 oh okay got it
yeah and then it's sort it's sort of the
same thing
so yeah rook c1 and rook all the way
down is the other way
rook c1 and then rook all the way down
to c8
oh okay i hypothetically played the
black rook to c7 so it would prevent
that but if
my opponent played something else then i
would go to c1 and then down to c8 okay
yeah
yes exactly that makes sense um by the
way just you suggested this move
pawn to d6
yes uh you still have the position on
the board with the bishop in the center
and then you sacrifice the queen right
uh yes and i just took the knight yes
yep so when you go d6 uh
what pieces see each other
for both sides white and black's pieces
they can see each other
um what pieces see each other
well i guess it depends on what black
moves before i play d6 right
no no well um let's say black just does
like something completely random
so a6 pushing upon okay yeah on to a6
and then i play
d6 um what
well now there's a discovered attack on
my opponent's rook
on b7 from my bishop yep
and your pawn is attacking the dark
squared bishop
yeah and my bishop is under attack by
the queen that
is the bonus yes you're still completely
winning because
the rook is hanging and your pawn's
about to like take everything and become
a queen
but just noticing that pushing a pawn
opens up the queen from the side
is uh another thing that you know
pattern recognition
right we'll we'll pick up yep uh
so yeah i mean this is uh
essentially how you like how you
have a an introductory kind of lesson
like we have to start somewhere
yeah right exactly so we took a look at
you know some different openings um
let me know if you had like specific
questions that you wanted answered
before you just get
off and practicing on your own whether
or not no i mean this this this is
definitely a lot to think about so
i'll i'll save some of my uh my written
down questions for the next one i think
no you can feel free i mean i try to
simplify them if you did you actually
have some written questions i always
have material prepared it's not
necessarily chess questions but it's
were there to be a lull in the
conversation i would have you know
something
to uh you know to refer back to but so
to to briefly get to youtube stuff for a
second
so a couple weeks ago your video started
appearing
in my in my recommended feed and
you know i watch other chess streamers
so it wasn't
totally clear exactly why but one thing
i noticed is like
there seems to be this industry of
everybody's thumbnails who's in the
chess space where there's a very similar
theme like
is there a consortium where you guys are
like this is how you do your thumbnails
or where does that come from
no no no no um i was inspired
i've only started doing youtube
seriously about two months ago and i've
been struggling for two and a half years
and i and i
i i don't have any sort of mechanism so
i just said i would primarily record for
youtube one off and i would not
upload i very rarely like this i will
post even as a stream but
right um so i kind of just said all
right i gotta
have like nice thumbnails because
otherwise they won't get any clicks
um and the wonderful gentleman who makes
gm hikarus
okay thumbnails he doesn't make mine uh
but i said hey do you have a friend
right and i
and uh he said yes so he put me in touch
and i kind of said like look we got to
put together
you know some some catchy thumbnails
because they got to get the clicks
and they don't have to be clickbaity or
or [ __ ] or any of that but sure
uh that is you know they need to be you
know big bold to the point
and that's kind of what they are and i
think like the
the video that youtube picked up and
started throwing into the algorithm was
this magnus carlsen invents an opening
yeah uh and that was from
a game that he played in a recently
concluded tournament
and uh it wasn't quite true like he
didn't invent it
but he was the guy that the first
high-level guy to play that way
well i once read that openings are
discovered not invented
yeah somebody put that on the video like
i had a lot of people listen some people
in that video were like hey man i played
this against my
my friend the other day magnus didn't
invent this and i was like guys like
chill out please uh so
yeah i would say that's better
discovered not invented um
but it seems like the your youtube
channel is going crazy i mean it so like
i'm looking on socialblade the first few
days
you of july you had a couple hundred new
subscribers
and you you got 2 700 new subscribers a
bunch of days in the last couple days
yeah it's been kind of insane um i think
about
two and a half weeks ago uh a a friend
of mine was like hey man congrats on
five
right and i was like yeah it's crazy you
know and i and i think i've just been
doing
just consistent stuff people like it
people like the thumbnails they also
like the material
yeah and i don't know it's maybe good to
have a fresh face like doing game recaps
and instructive stuff and i did notice
that there's a giant gap
on youtube like if you type in
chess strategy yeah it's the same
one-hour lectures you know that are not
they don't talk to the viewer it's
usually like to an audience and then
yeah
so i just said hey i'm just gonna give
it a shot and yeah people like it and
it's and the 10-minute format i think is
smart that you're doing
yeah yeah it's like i i started six to
like 12 and i know that 10 is this magic
number for
obviously monetization but i yeah i i
try not to like buff it up too much
like if it's seven it's seven right i'll
see no i mean keeping it
keeping it to 10 where somebody may just
want to be like i want to play a few
games i want a new opening i don't want
to spend an hour
on a long video i think that that's
smart but yeah i mean the chess boom has
just been crazy on on youtube and twitch
the last few months it's insane
it has been i really like to go to
google trends on youtube and youtube in
particular and just look up what chess
is and actually
a couple days ago it cracked me up
because on the left side it'll show
related terms
and it was like gotham american drama
series and i was like
that's because they're typing that's so
funny right um
i still can't get to like page one of uh
recommendation but
um are of like google trends but yeah
that's sort of the goal right now
so the um yeah i mean that that's so so
you're you're you're mostly doing the
live you're not doing any live stuff on
youtube right now
no no i'm like exclusively twitch for
streaming yeah got it
yeah the the algorithm so yes my some of
my audience knows yesterday i'll
randomly stream like
trump press conferences or press
briefings or whatever and
usually on youtube they'll get six to
eight thousand live viewers which is
great
uh but something happened yesterday
where they must have been like mistaking
fox news for my channel or something
i had 37 000 live viewers on youtube
during this just random 5 p.m
press conference and it's like it's just
crazy because i know that youtube's not
trying to send me 36 000 viewers but
every once in a while you just hit the
algorithm
um i don't know pot of gold or something
like that it's never really clear why
never will happen again i'm sure well
for for streaming i don't know how it
works but like for for the mag that
that one magnus video that's basically
what happened and it's so funny because
it
now when i do these comparisons of when
i upload videos it'll say like oh it's
like way at the bottom based on the
hours and the views because
a day or two into it the algo went nuts
yeah and i think the impressions
click-through rate was like 15 percent
for a while which is
insanity that's absolutely yeah so uh
and people were just like how
you who are you welcome to youtube you
know and that was the first one and then
i just started doing like a daily recap
and yeah
uh a while ago i made rating climb
videos so i started at a thousand
and i played blitz and did commentary
right and then those started picking up
and
uh yeah it's uh it's kind of insane but
youtube for like
you know for a content creator on the on
the income side passive income side is
insanity because twitter well more in
your field than in mine because i'm
doing a lot of my stuff gets stale but
what you're doing is
i wish i had something more evergreen ah
so this term is like
yeah i talked to eric rosen recently and
he used this term evergreen and i was
like
you make that term he's like no no no
that term was discovered not invented
there you go yeah uh awesome well listen
so so we'll figure out when the next one
is hopefully soon i mean
again as we've been saying i've been
invited to this tournament and hopefully
soon we'll be able to say more about
exactly what it is
i i'm wondering if there's this guy
named
hassan [ __ ] i don't know if you're
familiar with him but
on twitter yeah it's conceivable that he
may be in the tournament i don't know
i know that gm hikaru was was looking to
be in touch with him and he's he's
as far as i know a friend of mine i know
that there's there's some drama between
hassan and stephen kenneth destiny banel
ii
and you know there's a whole thing that
i don't participate in okay but
my hope is that uh there there's
somebody else i know
in the tournament if i'm so lucky to get
confirmed
oh very nice and so does that does that
motivate you to like
beat them like what does that do if
hassan beat me at chess i think it could
be a problem for my career yeah i think
it could be real problem
well there you go yeah so now you have
you have extra motivation
yeah uh it's it's good to have a
storyline in the tournament that's very
nice
these are completely fabricated but
somebody in my chat is somebody in my
chat is saying that stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell
ii is confirmed which is weird because i
didn't think anybody was confirmed i
thought it was just invite invitations
at this point but i guess we'll see
well yeah be before i get a very angry
uh message saying to shut it down
um no i mean obviously it's it's you
know we're
we're we're figuring it out i think it's
it's if if anyone's so late to the party
that they don't know this tournament is
happening
i sometimes do that because my chat will
be like hey could you leak something and
i'm like wait park champs 2 is happening
and uh they're like what so uh i told my
my chat if if one person gave a thousand
subs on their own
like then i would do something but yeah
i probably still won't so they'll report
me for fraud
well we don't want that we don't know we
we definitely don't
so i guess i'll i'll i'll catch up with
you offline and we'll figure out when
when we're doing the next one now i've
been assigned two coaches and i i
shouldn't say who the other one is yet
because you know again everything is so
so touch and go but how will that
interact why
why if i have two coaches that chess.com
would hypothetically assign me
in a tournament that may happen to which
i might have been invited
how will your coaching interact with
their coaching
uh so just make sure that it it kind of
supplements um
and i i guess that's sort of on the part
of these hypothetical coaches that you
have i didn't actually know that you had
a second coach
i was shocked to be perfect yeah that's
crazy i had no idea
uh um i think it's just you know it's
just to have these collaborations
hypothetically speaking
uh and it's it would be kind of on the
part of
both coaches to maybe talk about it as
well as just like you know prior be like
all right this is what i did with this
person got it got it got it got it oh
one more thing and not this is not this
might sound like a weird thing but a
bunch of people in my audience have been
asking about this
are there's this idea that super
high-level chess players are sometimes
savants in the sense of of autism
spectrum
okay is that something that you what's
your sense of that like is that is that
a thing because you know
it seems the ones that choose to stream
that's not the impression that i get but
i don't know what it's like at the big
tournaments
i think more often than not if you just
take the sample size
of like the top 40 uh
it that that that is a that is a pretty
fair point to make
oh interesting thing is i i think even
magnus himself has said this i think
even grishik so magnus being world
champion
i mean across the board yeah um grishok
has talked about this who's like
if you don't know who griez shook is
just go look up thug life griez shook
he's the guy the russian grand master
who
gives really funny interview answers um
it's it's it's a it's a fair point and
a lot of them i'm not sure how open they
are like to talk about it but a lot of
them are also more extroverted
than than others uh i mean that's why
hikaru is so successful because he
charismatic charming can manage a chat
of up to 45 000
you know people right um not everybody
can do that
sure so all of their personalities are
are a little bit different
um i don't know if there's been like a
study done on it
but if you then go to like
international masters i mean i have
always said like if i was more
anti-social
i would probably be a grandmaster
because i would have just spent a lot
less time just talking out of my ass
yeah right like so interesting yeah uh
but i think it's a
it's a fair point i will say it's not a
crazy question no no absolutely not okay
i think
in in the you know in the current day
and age um
we're we you know trying to be a little
bit like pc in the chess world so this
is not something we always talk about
but i feel like with you
uh having a collaboration i can very
openly just say that like
yes most likely it's very high
percentage
oh interesting hi that's interesting all
right very good well listen thank you so
much for
for you know starting to coach me um it
seems like i've not been
watching what's happening in your chat
but hopefully um nobody's been hugely
offended by anything i've done or said
no they love you no we got a good
community i think they were they were
very excited so awesome all right we'll
we'll be in touch offline and we'll set
up the next one
perfect have a good night this was all
right take care thank you so much
all right there we go what a what a day
um
an incredible uh victory
i would say um in the battle of ideas
and i did this one just
on twitch to start with conceivably we
you know we would push some of this
stuff
um multi-platform and uh you know it
could get very very crazy
but um that's gonna do it for me we've
got a very
very long day tomorrow potentially
uh donald trump press briefing kaylee
maganny you know we'll get back to
politics tomorrow but
it's gonna be a real party so i'll talk
to everybody later